Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
I'm your host Rawkode. Today,
we're gonna be taking a look at Litmus,
a chaos engineering project that aims to bring
chaos engineering to Kubernetes in a cloud native
and Kubernetes
Kubernetes native fashion.
Now, before we get started on taking a
look at that project, I also just want
to encourage you to please subscribe to the
YouTube channel and click the bell, and also
join our Discord community where we have lots
of conversation during the show and after the
show to discuss all the projects that we
cover.
Now joining me today to discuss Litmus
are members
of the Chaos Native team, Ooma and Kartik.
Hi there. How are you both?
Doing great,
David. Thanks for inviting us here. Happy to
be here. Looking forward to this
live session.
Yeah. I think chaos engineering is is getting
a lot more traction. I see a lot
more people talking about it day after day,
month after month, and I'm really excited to
be able to just
get a taste for what Litmus can do
to my Kubernetes cluster, both good and bad.
And then also worried about what is gonna
uncover in some of my actual production clusters.
But
I guess that's a problem that we all
have to tackle eventually.
Do you both wanna just, take a a
few moments to kind of introduce yourself, tell
us a little bit about you, and then
we'll start talking about Litmus.
Sure.
Again, thank you, and happy to be here.
I'm Omar Mukhara, CEO of Chaos Native, also
I'm, a maintainer on the Litmus
Chaos project,
which is now in, CNCF sandbox.
To tell a little bit, more about me,
I live in Bangalore,
with my two sons and my wife.
Basically
have been a technology architect in the past.
About ten years ago, I jumped into entrepreneurship
with,
starting CloudByte storage company,
which then we,
pivoted into Open EBS to write storage for
Kubernetes,
which is, still,
one of, the popular projects in CNCF.
And then while I was doing,
Open EBS project, we tried to do chaos
engineering for Open EBS. That's when Rawkode and
I started writing,
Litmus,
which became a CNCO project,
and then we recently spun off, the project
from MyData into
a company for,
its own development. The projects are to focus
on this project, and it's chaos, native.
We also have launched,
a chaos conference called Chaos Carnival,
to focus, more on cloud native chaos engineering
and also a little bit more open and,
open for everyone kind of a thing. So
that's a bit of my introduction. Looking forward
to, this session here.
Cool. Let me go ahead and introduce myself.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Kartik.
I'm a lead maintainer of the Litmus Chaos
project,
also from Chaos Native.
So
I have a shared history with Ooma.
We worked on
Open ABS,
MyData,
and
he came up with Litmus as a way
to test the resilience of OpenEBS over a
period of time
while it's useful for everyone else and if
you had separate project.
I'm having a blast maintaining Litmus and interacting
with the community,
and I'm really looking forward to this session.
Yeah. Glad to be here.
Awesome. Thank you very much. So I believe
we've got some slides where we're gonna just
kinda cover
what that message and give everybody a little
bit extra flavor. So if we can get
that screen shared, we'll jump through to the
slides, and then we'll move on to the
hands on component afterwards.
Awesome. Thank you very much.
Alright.
You, David.
So
with that introduction,
I just want to take about ten to
fifteen minutes.
After that, I think David has plenty of
a live session,
with Litmus.
So
what I want to do here really is
talk very briefly about chaos engineering that we
all know of
and the the new cloud native chaos engineering
and then introduce the project, why we started
Litmus, really.
So quickly, chaos engineering is all about
avoiding
downtimes.
Unplanned downtimes are always expensive.
Right? So you don't want to be that
doing that. So
what we are seeing so far in the
last decade is
test, don't wait. Right? So you do the
testing on the operation
side of your DevOps loop and then find
the issues or tunables that are needed,
and get back into the shape. Right? So
this is, we know that.
So so far, it's all about,
trying to do it on demand or
you do chaos engineering
after you
burn your hands with, some expensive downtime, that's
really
been the case. And,
proactive chaos engineering
is slowly catching up. The reason why so
many things are,
happening around chaos engineering is there is a
real push, from the new ecosystem around cloud
native.
I'll get to that. But, so far, how
it's been done is,
you know, it's it's done based on a
need, and it is generally done by SREs
on the operation side of it.
You don't have a very tight integration of
kiosk engineering itself in CA and CD.
And, generally, observability is not a a preplanned
thought, rather it is an afterthought.
And
communicating
with management, convincing the management is all based
on the need. Right? So chaos engineering is
a great practice. That is a proven practice,
but it is not like a science where
everybody knows how to do it. Or it's
not as easy as, you know I know
Kubernetes, but I also know how to do
chaos engineering on Kubernetes. Right? So that's that's
not how it's been till recently.
But chaos engineering
is starting to begin. We all know that
Kubernetes
itself is, you know, has crossed the chasm.
Everyone is
in the middle of adopting it or already
adopting it adopted it. But the chaos engineering
for Kubernetes is still only market, I would
say. That really means that there are new
tools being available.
People are beginning
to think that we need chaos engineering now
that they adopted, Kubernetes.
Right? So we are going to see a
lot of,
innovation.
Peep people like us trying to put chaos
engineering into mainstream,
for bringing resilience into Kubernetes.
Right? So now let me talk a little
bit about cloud native chaos engineering.
It's really about,
you know, trying to do chaos engineering specifically
for cloud native environments.
I would call it as a cloud native
chaos engineering.
So what's so different about it? Right?
So,
these are the five principles that we think,
should be different about chaos engineering.
Right? Kubernetes
and the regular cloud native ecosystem would not
be as popular as it is today if
it is not for open source. Right? So
chaos engineering should also be built,
maintained
in open source. Right? So that's that's one
thing that we see.
And, also, it should be community collaborated.
Like, all the helm charts, chaos charts, chaos
experiments, chaos workflows
should be,
you know, developed
in collaboration with the community.
Then it becomes much easier. There are going
to be much,
you know, resilient, the test itself.
There's less chance of false alarms and all.
And then chaos engineering,
you start, and then you end up maintaining
all your scripts. So there is going to
be an operator of its own, versioning of
the chaos experiments.
So you need to have custom resources, open
API around that.
Then comes how do you scale it? How
do you scale your chaos experiments for a
system that's got hundreds and thousands of nodes,
multiple clusters, cross cloud, all this stuff?
We just need to be able to manage
chaos engineering just the way how you've been
managing your Kubernetes configuration itself.
That is through GitOps.
Right? So GitOps should be applied for chaos
engineering also.
And
the last one, but they're not the least,
how do you actually
know that a fault has happened?
Because you introduced it or there was an
actual fault. Obviously, when we introduce
a fault or multiple faults,
you're going to have some description, and you
want to understand what's going on there. Oh,
okay. This is still alright because I introduced
it. Now I exactly know where to look
at. So that's called observability.
Observability is a super key thing. We call
it as open observability. You don't want to
get logged in into some of the observability
tools. You basically try to keep open standards
around that. So this is what
I call as a set of
chaos engineering principles for cloud native environment.
And
we built Litmus project
exactly around these principles.
Right? We started about
around thirty months ago starting to build the
first Litmus project or a little bit more
than that. And we started in open source.
We built a chaos hub, chaos operators,
and then now we built a cross cloud
control plane for chaos engineering
where you can run, chaos engineering on Kubernetes,
off Kubernetes in the same fashion. You can
scale them up using GitOps.
You can do the observability.
So we're almost there with the two dot
zero coming out, you know, soon. We're announcing
we just announced the beta is coming on
March 15.
So I'm looking forward to, having more feedback,
coming from the community.
So the status of the project itself,
it's pretty wide event. I would say even
the chaos native or we are known as
the team was under my data.
We are the prime sponsors or maintenance.
There are a lot of contributions coming in
from all over the places.
Right? You can see some of these guys,
the number in the brackets are a combination
of either PR submitted, review previews, and
a number of issues created and so on
and so forth.
But we are also happy to say that
we are now closer to 50,000 installations of
this, and we are pretty soon going to
go into
at least the application for incubation is already
out there. Hopefully, in the next few months,
we'll get to that state.
And a lot of traction from various,
companies
apart from Chaos Native.
You know, we would I would say more
than thousand,
users in various forms are there, but
these are some of the primary users that
we've been seeing, either contributing
or using
in some form.
Right? And, primarily, the use cases for Litmus
is pretty straightforward.
You can use them in CA pipelines
when you're testing your code. You can do
chaos testing.
And you can also use Litmus as a
trigger for your CD
that you
your code is good.
Now it can be deployed in production.
And later,
you can also
kick start chaos engineering once the deployment is
done. Right? And you can also use it
along with GitOps. And,
you know, in general, CSED is, one of
the, main reasons.
And then, obviously,
you use chaos engineering in production,
start with, staging, and then move on into
production, etcetera, etcetera. Right? So at the outset,
it's pretty simple. Litmus is,
one installation for the entire enterprise kind of
a thing. You have an helm chart. You
get Litmus portal. You bring in,
the experiments from the chaos hub. You can
also set up a private chaos hub to
manage the experiments,
maintain the experiments among your team members or
set of teams. It's like how you manage
any other infrastructure code
or the code itself. Right? So once you
set up, Litmus,
you get a Litmus portal, and then you
run chaos workloads on any Kubernetes cluster as
a target. Or now it is also possible
to set VMs or bare metal as a
target also. Right? And then you can, put
all this configuration into any other, CD tool,
like Argo CD, Plug CD,
or,
Spinnaker or Jenkins
x, and then, you know, move forward with
that. So in a nutshell, Litmus is one,
distributed chaos engineering tool,
where you can manage all your chaos engineering
needs
for all of your team members
and then run your chaos workflows or experiments
at various targets
and then have all the results,
pushed back into,
Prometheus,
and you have a single pane of
observability
for,
knowing what's going on. Right? So one of
the innovations that we did to achieve the
scale and, flexibility
is to integrate with our goal. Right? So
now at the at the lower levels, it
has its own operator chaos experiments.
But at the upper level, it is integrated
into other workflow.
It is not an Argo workflow by itself,
but Argo workflow plus some intelligence to consolidate,
the status of, the experiments and results. And
then this is how we actually do,
GitOps and chaos engineering together. Right?
So this is a little bit of a
details.
You will write a chaos workflow,
and then, you write, within that, you'll have
a chaos engine. The moment you write a
chaos engine, the operator picks it up, runs
the experiments, and then we push the result
and metrics back into,
Prometheus metrics or,
any other observability tool that we support.
And, we keep these experiments either in a
hub,
in public hub, or you can also pull
them into private hub.
It's nothing but a private gate repository where
you manage your experiments, and the workflows can
use a mix of experiments from both the
hubs or many other hubs as well. Right?
So we do have a lot of experiments
that are required.
I think we have about 40 plus experiments
today,
which are generally sufficient enough,
to do the basic chaos engineering,
advanced chaos engineering if needed. And, obviously, this
is an open source project that is going
to grow more and more. So, there's always
some new experiment that's coming. So we do
have, some fantastic experiments new experiments that are
going to come out in the next, three
to six months.
We also do, have a built in, observability
analytics,
within Litmus.
And, also, you can use the chaos annotations
and metrics
to put chaos indicators
in your regular drop on the charts as
well. So observability is an important piece for
us, and we continue to improve
that part of the area.
And when it comes to the integrations,
we are doing more and more with the
help from community.
Currently, we have integrations into GitLab, GitHub actions,
Spinnaker. Recently, we did fantastic integrations into another
sincere project, called Captain.
So, basically, what happens is you can introduce
chaos stages into those respective tools,
which uses
a CI library from Litmus,
which underneath
will invoke the regular CI Litmus experiments.
So it's pretty easy to integrate.
And we are also having architecture to introduce,
chaos onto non Kubernetes targets. In this case,
the experiments itself will run,
on Kubernetes,
as an agent, And then using the remote
network APIs,
of the respective target,
we'll be introducing chaos. So it's a little
bit early right now, but we do have
experiments,
for a few experiments for Amazon and Google,
but a lot more are coming.
And we see this area
is a great
area for collaborating with the with the community
at large.
So we're also having a lot of plans
to integrate
with the CNC of projects,
plus cross plane, OPA. We people keep coming.
Okay. We are using OPA for security and
policy control reasons.
Chaos engineering also should be integrated into it.
Why not? I think, you know, there is
some work that's coming up.
So before I leave it back to demo,
you know, Chaos Native, it's it's about,
you know, we continue to provide,
free
support,
ad code, you to the project, but we
are also starting to the purpose of Kiosk
need to also use to,
increase the adoption of Litmus,
in the enterprises where they expect, the enterprise
support
and many services. So we have started,
these services,
in some form already.
I took few users. Looking forward to, hearing
more on this from the users and,
and the community
and enterprises,
themselves.
With that, I would like to say thank
you very much for giving this opportunity. We'll
turn it back on on to,
the live session now. David, back to you.
Alright. Thank you very much. I
guess maybe we could just take a
before we jump straight into the hands on
section, why don't we kinda tackle a few
questions there? Like, I think you made it
very clear that, you know, in order to
do,
you you know, any sort of chaos within
a cluster is that monitoring and observability
are almost paramount.
What
would happen, you know, if I don't have
very good monitoring observability and I let let
miss loosen my cluster? I mean, is that
just gonna all go bad?
I
mean, like, basically, chaos itself is you're disrupting
something that's working. Right? So the idea is
you disrupt something which you expect might happen,
and then you see whether my service are
up or light. Right?
So what happens to your cluster really depends
on what is the chaos that you are
introducing.
And,
yeah, you know, you could
use a node
kill experiment
and then kill all the nodes, then, yeah,
you can bring it down. Right? That's very
much possible. But the idea of observability
is somebody knows that they are doing it.
Right? That they're doing chaos.
So
the blast radius could be huge or could
be low,
but sometimes
you
have to have an eye on
what's happening
with chaos as a perspective in it. Right?
For example,
I have my Graphana
chart or any other chart showing
the CPU usage of all my services on
my cluster.
And now
for a certain amount of time,
couple of hours ago,
there was disruptions everywhere.
And was it the time that chaos was
introduced, and what was the chaos that was
introduced, in which namespace it was introduced?
That perspective, when you have it within your
observability
tool, it makes hundred times easier for whoever
it is looking at to debug. Otherwise, you
know, you are just throwing
more,
disturbance into the system,
And you know that something is wrong, we
are debugging. The purpose of chaos engineering itself
is to find what's wrong with the service.
You debug and you fix it. So observability
is is pretty important in that. At this
marking that this is the chaos
that I introduced during this period, having that
available for the users is is very important.
Yeah. Definitely. I think that makes a lot
of a lot of sense.
I think, you know, I like to think
of this as, like, you know, we write
code
based on assumptions that we think this is
what the code is doing. And then we
correct that or we test that with tests.
And I feel like this is a good
application of that to our production infrastructure or
I guess any of our environments and that,
you know, we run these
applications
that are horizontally scalable and fault tolerant.
At least that's what it says on the
box. But how often do we actually ever
test that? How do we know that if
I lose a node or if I lose
a Kafka consumer that that is gonna be
moved over to another machine or picked up
by another horizontally scalable pod. And Litmus is
the way for us to take those assumptions
and actually make them assertions that actually confirm
that the behavior works the way that we
want. And I think that
is is really powerful.
Is this something
you know, based on the experience of you
using this yourself in OpenEPS and and the
customers that you're speaking or spoken to,
do people run this in production, or do
they run it in preproduction environments?
Our experience
I mean, nobody starts,
not just Litmus or any other chaos engineering
directly in production.
One of the challenges always for the SREs
that, we keep hearing is,
you know, I finally determined that chaos engineering
is going to help me make my systems
better,
but my
management is not yet approved. Right? So how
they do typically is
they don't even go into preproduction. They go
into a little bit of a staged environment
and always
I mean, nowadays, the
the upgrade environments
are pretty
robust,
and people invest in a chain of the
stages. You go with the development
and then staging, preproduction,
and then production. These are at least the
four stages that we know of, and some
people may have even
more stages than that. Right? So
it is okay to start with the development
itself.
Right? So
chaos engineering should be thought of as a
next step to the development if possible. Right?
So that's how
at least our project makes it totally declarative
where however you write a code to deploy
a Kubernetes resource,
you write one more declarative interface
to do some testing around it. Right? So
it's very easy, and it comes as an
extension to your development process. So you can
start with
that
and then into CI pipelines. Right? You introduce
a chaos stage,
and then you start with very small tests.
You have nothing to lose if your CI
pipeline breaks totally. In fact, it's a good
thing that you're breaking right now.
And then we go into the staging and
then run it for a few months. You
see value in it. You get a chance
to convince both your developers,
your own teammates, and your management,
and then run a game day on your
staging
and then go into production. Right? So that's
typically how it's done, and
we have seen significant results being produced in
that fashion.
Alright. Thank you very much. We have a
couple of questions from the audience, so let
me pop the first one up there.
And, Mozz, welcome back. Nice to see you
again. Has asked how big of a hardware
network and resources that Litmus requires to be
running inside of our cluster?
Right. The new
Litmus,
we are talking about two dot zero. Right?
The Litmus so far, one dot x,
till a couple of months ago is you
need to install Litmus on every Kubernetes cluster
wherever you're going to run. Right? Now we
are trying to make Litmus into more of
an infrastructure tool set
for your entire Kubernetes,
ecosystem, not just one cluster,
but for a set of team members. Right?
So,
for that, you need to install Litmus application.
And to begin with, it is, you know,
the amount of resources are of a mega
of, memory and, of a CPU is good
enough. But it is a Kubernetes application.
It is highly scalable.
And the more,
experiments that you run,
it just can take up, more resources as
you need. But we try to keep it,
as thin as possible,
And it's about op mega of RAM and
the op of CPU should be good enough.
Kartik, you want to add something more to
that, please? Go ahead.
Yep. I think you have answered it. Having
said that, the chaos
control plane
and the chaos parts that are launched from
the experiments
can have the resources defined for them in
a declarative way. So we'll talk about that
when we see the chaos engine custom resource.
So you can define the requirements,
the limits that you want there in case
you are running a lot of experiments in
parallel, etcetera. You you could control that.
The minimum requirements, as Omar said, are low,
But they may
add up to more when you're running a
lot of experiments in parallel, but you can
control them.
Yeah. So it's it's pretty lightweight. But if
you go if you wanna cause absolute carnage
in your cluster, of course, the resource consumption
is gonna grow within a number of experiments
that you wanna deploy. So, I think that
makes a lot of sense.
And I guess the answer was there is,
whatever you wanna throw at it.
Okay. We got another question from Vishal.
Does Litmus allow us to schedule chaos? I
mean, like, if I want to I'm assuming
and I'll I'll throw some extra words in
there. Is that if I want to see
next week at 3AM, I wanna run some
sort of
availability zone failure scenario. Is that something that
is possible with Litmus?
Yep.
Yeah. Scheduling is one of the core features
of
the project.
We allow it in various forms,
and you can run it instantly. You can
schedule it, and you can
rerun a previous one, many forms of it,
right, every hour,
every day, every week, and you can do
multiple combinations of that.
Nice. Well, I think that's plenty of of
chitchat as hopefully people interest has peaked. I
think we've said a lot of really interesting
stuff. I'm really I I really wanna see
this in action. So I believe are
gonna walk us through and guide us through
the installation and then some more advanced demos
as well on top of So I'm very
excited, and I will hand over to you.
You're on mute, I'm afraid.
Sorry about that. Let me share my screen.
Awesome. Thank you.
I hope my screen is visible.
It is. You are live. Please take it
away.
Alright.
So this is the agenda we have for
today.
We'll do a quick run through of the
Litmus installation.
What you'll see on the documentation today
involves installation of the Litmus operator,
pulling the experiments from the chaos hub,
and then running the actual chaos.
What we'll do today is
install the Litmus version that is upcoming.
We have it already in beta. So we
have a component called the portal,
which is essentially a web UI which will
help you orchestrate chaos. So we'll do a
quick installation on Litmus.
After that, we have,
a real world chaos scenario. We've taken,
Kafka
workload,
a stateful set Kafka cluster,
upon which we will run some test load
and kill one of the brokers,
and we'll see what happens. And, we'll see
how you can hypothesize
about
the behavior of Kafka when you inject this
chaos, how you can place that hypothesis in
a declarative way in, like, Kubernetes custom resource,
called the Litmus Chaos Engine.
And after that, if we have some time,
we'll do chaos on AWS,
cloud. We'll do a kill of an easy
two instance and verify the health of the
application that is going to be impacted by
it. So this is how we this is
what we have for the agenda and the
more objectives.
I'll very quickly go ahead and show you
the procedure to install Litmus.
So we have the Litmus chaos slash Litmus.
This is the repository,
and I am inside a folder called as
Litmus portal.
You could install it via Kubernetes manifest like
this,
a standard
YAML file,
or you can also do it via Helm
chart. We have a help repository
at Litmus chaos slash Litmus help. So you
can pick your, bundles from there.
For now, I'm just going to use my
manifest.
I've got two clusters with me,
cluster one and cluster two, both around GKE.
I'm going to install the Litmus portal on
cluster two.
And while that is going to come up,
we'll move to do the app chaos demo
on cluster one in which I have already
installed the Litmus Litmus components.
And before we get on to doing the
app chaos, I'll also show you another slide
which talks about the demo setup and the
use case and the hypothesis,
all that. For now, let's just
install Litmus. I have
a VM instance here,
which I can use
to install
resources on my Kubernetes
cluster.
So it creates Litmus namespace.
As you can see, I have executed a
command before where there is no Litmus namespace.
We create a Litmus namespace. We create some
dependencies
like the config maps
and persistent volumes,
and then we actually deploy
the Litmus microservices.
So Litmus has a control plane that consists
of the
a GraphQL server.
It has a MongoDB to store the state
of chaos,
and it also has
a few other RBAC related resources that get
installed
when you do the installation.
Oops.
Alright.
Now you can see I have the three
part running with the front end, which is
actually the UI, this GraphQL server, and then
this MongoDB.
I'm going to try and access this,
right, and
bring up the UI on my
browser.
As we do this, if there are any
questions, David, please feel free to interrupt me.
I can take those questions as we go
along. Yeah. Definitely. Using NodePort,
as you can see by default here, let
me find out
the
external IPs of one of my nodes,
and I'll use that to bring up the
portal.
So this is the IP, and I've got
32527.
I've already exposed these ports
on my firewall.
I hope that's right.
Okay.
Yeah. You can see the portal is now
opening up.
By default, it takes admin and admin as
the username and password.
I think so.
Okay. What's wrong? It is admin and Litmus.
So once I get into the portal,
I have the option to set up my
project. So the Litmus portal allows you to,
create your own project. Is each user is
allowed to create his own project,
his or her own project into which they
can invite other team members,
and they can invite team members in different
roles as view admins
or
as people who have edit access and can
run chaos.
You we could do different things.
I'm just going to create a different project
called Rawkode.
I'm just going to fill in some details
here.
It's going to provide some information.
Alright. So it has updated the details.
I'll just navigate on this browser
and just show you the different options that
you have for a few minutes before we
go ahead and do some experiments.
Like, Uma was mentioning, in case of Litmus,
the unit of execution of chaos is workflows.
So your workflow could be just one chaos
injection,
or it could be a set of chaos
injections
ordered in a particular manner in sequence or
in parallel.
You could also use workflows to run some
kind of a benchmark load or some other,
test workloads along with chaos just to see
how it behaves under stress. So workflows are
pretty flexible. You can construct them using the
browser, the the portal,
browser, or you can actually create them on
Git, source them into your,
both portal instance and execute it as well.
You can create predefined workflows.
We also ship what's called as the my
hub. That is a chaos hub
inside the the request portal. The chaos hub
that you see here is the same as
the one you notice,
in
public here at, up. It was chaos.io.
So this is some kind of an open
marketplace
you can think for chaos.
So this is where our community is focused
on contributing experiments into on picking experiments from.
There are some categories of experiments here. The
most used ones
or the most used experiments are from the
generic category. Most of the standard Kubernetes,
fault injections are available here. But there are
also experiments
of other categories.
For example, we have open APS and some
Kafka and some Cassandra experiments.
These are essentially the same faults as you
would see in the genetic experiments along with
some native
checks that are,
very specific to these applications. And they can
also consist of experiments
that are related on specifically to that app
and they're not general Kubernetes for failures or,
those kind of things.
So you have an instance of the hub
embedded in your request portal.
So you can construct workflows by picking experiments
off the hub.
But it's also possible for you to connect
your own kiosk hub. Let's say,
you have your own downstream
implementation of request experiments and you have that
in a private hub.
You can actually pull that,
where it has some access tokens and use
that for creating workflows.
As of now, I have a workflow which
is already constructed, so I'm going to use
that.
Let me move to the target section.
So the target is how we call
chaos execution environment.
So in this case,
the same cluster that has this particular portal
installed
is also the target, which is also called
self cluster and Litmus terminology,
and it shows that it is active.
But I could also connect other Kubernetes clusters
here. I can connect a target,
and,
request portal will actually communicate,
with that cluster and inject chaos there via
some agents.
So I have this local cluster self registered.
That is the portal is installed on this
cluster, and it is also an object of
chaos.
And once that happens, you will actually see
a few more parts being spun up here.
You can see something called, like, a subscriber.
You're doing essentially the agent. Which is actually
going to relay instructions from your portal onto
your cluster target.
And there are some workflow controllers,
the chaos operator,
and a few other other micro services, which
we can talk about later,
which help you to do chaos in a
better manner.
So with this,
I can go ahead and quickly jump to
the demo environment
that I actually wanted to show you and
do chaos on. So we are done with
the installations
part of Litmus. The portal has been installed.
It's as simple as this.
And I can go ahead and run new
experiments
by creating a new workflow. I can schedule
a workflow,
and I can
select the target on which I want to
do chaos.
There are some predefined workflows
just for illustrative purposes that we've created. You
can feel free to use them, or you
could create your own workflow.
And when you create your own workflow, you
have a few options.
You can select them from the chaos hub,
like I said. You can select the experiment
here,
and
you could choose to go ahead and add
tunables for a particular experiment.
This will eventually give you
a chaos engine manifest,
which looks something like this.
I can show you that once I finished
adding more experiments.
So this will actually open up a browser,
which is going to show you
the manifest that is actually going to be
created on your target cluster when you run
chaos.
This looks very similar to an Rawkode workflow,
like Paul mentioned, but it has
a few other characteristics.
The steps are executed by a specific image
which understands Litmus API.
And this is called the chaos engine,
which is
essentially how you define your chaos experiment to
be like.
And,
this is a very quick snapshot.
It has,
some references about what application you want to
do chaos on
and what experiment you actually want to perform
and and what are some of the tunables
or options you want to run the experiment
with.
That's what the engine,
exemplifies.
It is essentially,
a definition of how you want to do
your chaos, what chaos you want to do,
how you want to do it, and what
application you want to do, what are the
run properties you would associate with the chaos
experiment.
All that can be defined here.
And, the workflow embeds this chaos in in
a long way. If you are the steps
that are setting up dependencies,
then you go ahead and run this. I
don't have an application right now in this
cluster to do my chaos on. So I'll
just stop at this point,
and I'll
probably go ahead and show you the demo
environment where we'll do the actual chaos today.
Before we go there, I just wanted to
know if there are any questions
around the installation process.
Yes. I think the the installation looked really
simple, which is great. There were a couple
of things that popped into my head as
as you were working through that. Yeah.
Like,
it's using it's actually using Argo under the
hood to do this to do this. Right?
So it's kinda working hand in hand with
that project,
which I thought was That's true. Yeah. Really
nice
rather, you know, reinventing the wheel and doing
something completely bespoke. So I like that. We
also had a a question from Miles who
asked, is it possible to target a specific
workload in deployment? And I think you just
kind of showed that if you could pull
that YAML back up.
Yeah. I think that's a great question.
Thanks for asking that, Miles.
Yeah.
Litmus,
one of the crucial differentiators of Litmus is
the fact that
we
can isolate,
the chaos targets to the workload.
For example, if you have a deployment
that you want to do chaos on and
you don't want chaos to be
you you want to just restrict the blast
radius to that deployment alone and or maybe
any other downstream application that's depending on that
deployment, but not any other application.
You could choose to do that in the
way you construct your chaos engine.
There are,
some annotation checks that you can do. You
can turn on in Litmus, and it's going
to look for chaos annotation on a particular
workload,
and it's going to filter only those applications
that has
those annotations and also has the label selectors
that you mentioned,
and it's going to kill only that.
I I will show that chaos engine in
slightly more detail
when we do the Kafka demonstration.
But I'd also like to
just augment what
David said about the workflows.
I think you made a great point about
not reinventing the wheel,
David. So when we started off Litmus, and
this is how you'll find it in the
current documentation as well,
the custom resources that were brought up for
Litmus were capable of doing experiments in a
particular way, individual experiments.
But we thought there's a lot of value
in allowing users to run complex scenarios
because,
you know, misfortune doesn't come singly. Sometimes it
comes in clusters.
So you have more than one failure occurring
at a given point of time.
All the same, a lot of people want
to do failure testing when they're running performance
workloads.
When they're doing performance testing, they also want
to do some chaos and see how things
are behaving.
We found Argo as
workloads as a way to enable that. And
in fact, the idea was brought on board
by one of our engineers from Intuit,
Sumit, who was using Litmus that way and
then suggested, why don't you actually make it
the unit of execution within Litmus?
So I think that that that's the backstory
behind using
Argo.
Okay.
I'm curious as well. You showed the, like,
the chaos hub.
I mean, are there any plans to use
the artifact hub as a way to store
these chaos experiments?
That that's a great question.
We have had this we have touched upon
this in the past,
specifically when we contributed
Litmus to CNCF as a sandbox project.
Right now, the hub lives as it as
its individual
entity,
and
the artifact hub has the artifacts for deploying
Litmus.
Both the the Litmus control plane, and you
can also have the Litmus experiments being installed
via,
manifest that you pull from the artifact hub.
So the Litmus experiments that you see here,
you can actually install them via manifest,
And the the hub provides you more context
and metadata about a given experiment,
what it's going to do, and why it's
useful, and what are the
artifacts associated with that. There's an experiment CR.
Then there's a recommended service account that you
run your experiment with. So in Litmus, each
experiment is associated with the service account which
you could choose to use
because
we felt that in a multi tenant environment
when people are running in a self-service model,
each running their own experiments, you don't really
want them to run experiments with
all the permissions that they can get.
We just defined a minimum set of permissions
for each experiment.
We are recommending users to use that, but
it's not necessary. If you're if you have
autonomy over the cluster, you can have an
all encompassing service account that does all the
experiment.
But we have all that information around what
this experiment does and what are the, you
know, associated
manifest, all that in the hub.
Whereas
in the artifact hub, you will find the
same experiments available for installation as a helm
chart.
So
we have a space for both to coexist,
but it is a possibility.
We really don't know what holds for the
future.
As the project grows, we can see and
see if we might probably revisit
this
this topic and this discussion to see how
this hub can go on, whether it can
run individually or whether
it goes and gets merged into Artifact Hub.
For now, I think Artifact Hub and the
chaos hub both provide you options to pick
experiments from. Okay. I'm gonna ask you a
very difficult question now, but I think the
most important one of the day, like, does
the mascot have a name?
We call it the chaos bird.
There's a very interesting blog.
I can probably share that on the
livestream comments later.
As to how this came about,
we've we wanted to,
you know, make it a very restless
sort of little thing, which always does experiments
so you can see it wearing some kind
of a coat Yep. Always going about a
a lab,
trying to do some experiments.
So that was the general idea, and you
will you'll find a lot of the mascot
in the Litmus website as well in different,
pauses.
So, yeah, I think it's,
something we got positive feedback on.
People like the
the chaos bird.
So yeah. Yeah. Definitely 10 out of 10.
In fact, I've gotta say, like, the design
and aesthetic of the dashboards as well and
the logo, like, it it's all just really
polished and cool, and I definitely need to
get some chaos bird stickers now. Like, definitely
one of my favorite cloud native mascots.
Anyways, that's a small segue but I just
had to see that was awesome. I really
like it. So,
you know, I I know we're about to
do a more advanced demo and maybe you'll
tackle this here but there's something that's kinda
popped into my mind, you know. I can
imagine me running this in mean, I'm
a little bit crazy at times and I
will run this in production. I know I
will because I wanna really test this in
a real world situation.
If things are going badly with an experiment,
is there a way to revert, undo, delete,
stop?
Am I committed to the chaos, or can
I pull out of the chaos?
You could.
So the Litmus supports
an ability to abort experiments.
So
each chaos resource in Litmus
has an engine state,
which is essentially reflective of
the current state of your experiment.
It is always set to active by default.
You can go patch it to stop something
that is going to be made available in
the portal. You could disable portals for the
portal today. I mean, you could disable the
workflow in the portal today.
That's essentially going to stop it from getting
picked and stop the kiosk from getting rescheduled.
We also have
the about feature coming up on the portal.
It's already supported by the back end if
you're doing things by hand. You just need
to patch
your chaos resource with a particular state, and
it's going to revert all the existing,
chaos processes that have been started. Let's say
I'm doing some kind of network chaos
where I've gone and injected some
rules network rules on the network namespace of
the remote container targets.
By
botting the experiment,
those processes are going to be rolled back.
And all the kiosk pods that were brought
up to do the experiment to validate the
hypothesis,
etcetera, they are going to be removed as
well. And there is something called as a
chaos result.
That's another custom resource. It is an artifact
that's generated at runtime,
which is going to have information of what
happened thus far in your experiment and the
current state that it was aborted.
You know a future that, okay, this was
a run that was stopped. I can either
restart it, or I can clear everything and
start fresh again with the new hypothesis.
So that's an option you could do. And
it is something that
we got a lot of feedback on early
when we started the project
about a couple of years back. So we
said, we want to use Litmus in production.
We really want it to be able to
roll back
the chaos and stop things immediately.
And, yes, we recently, we're able to demonstrate
that we could you could do this at
scale as well. Let's say you're doing chaos
on
hundreds of replicas at a given point of
time,
so you need to be able to stop
chaos in all of them. So that's something
that we we already support on a per
experiment basis.
The portal is going to enable that to
be done for a workflow basis. I think
that should be available very soon.
Nice.
Okay. Let's tackle one more question, and then
I'll let you get back to your demo.
Boss has asked a great question here. And
what he's asking is, can I configure the
signal sent to my application so that I
can handle maybe a graceful termination rather than
a sec, which would be more of an
abrupt termination of my application?
Sure.
There are a couple of
experiments that you would see on the the
chaos hub.
I hope my the chaos hub is visible.
It is. So you could you
could see there is a bar delete experiment,
something we also conducted a little earlier,
And it has,
a few options
for you to define the nature of
the kill.
For example, nature of the delete, you could
do it with force. You could do it
without force
Flags, if you do it with force flags,
you're going to have a zero termination
grace period seconds, and it's going to immediately
remove your part.
That's about the part delete, an API driven
part delete. There's also another experiment,
an interesting one called container kill experiment,
which is a lot to do with signals,
the nature of the signals that you can
push to your
application.
So by default,
Kubernetes
sends the the sit down. And if you
if you do have hooks that you already
have,
some kind of pre stop hooks,
then
you will allow those to gracefully complete before
actually going and killing it off at the
end of the,
period termination grace period seconds that you might
have defined for your application.
But container kill experiment allows you to specify
the nature of
the,
the termination that you pass your app containers.
You can send sit downs, sit kills, all
those kind of things. It's something that is,
this is an experiment that is more of
a remnant of the previous era before Kubernetes
where Docker and Docker Swarm used to rule
the rules,
and
it could do a Docker kill.
Right? That work. But it's something that you
don't see too much in the Kubernetes world
today. You generally go and sit down, and
then you can provide some grace period seconds
for your application.
And you can factor in how long you
want to wait for your application to recover
before you
validate your hypothesis or come to the final
conclusion around what happened to your app.
By that, let me elaborate.
Litmus allows you to provide something called as
status check
timeouts. I'm just opening up the API specification
for Litmus or rather what all you can
provide in the Litmus Chaos engine
resource, the Chaos custom resource. There is something
called as the
status
check timeout.
It's essentially how long do you want for
your application wait for your application to recover
before
you actually call out the experiment as a
failure or as a success. So these are
things that you can,
tune where actually running your experiment depending upon
your use case. What is the nature of
your application? What are its dependencies? For example,
sometimes you stateful applications which
need more TVs.
So you might delete them on one node.
It has to get rescheduled on another node,
but it has to mount the TV before
it actually comes up. How much time does
that typically take depends upon your stateful
storage solution provider.
There are so many variables depending upon your
app type and your experiment use case itself.
So you could choose a lot of things,
a lot of
hooks and Litmus to help you arrive at,
you know, the correct
result,
so to say. As far as the injection
is concerned, with the bot delete experiment, you
could do force and non you could do
force deletes and the graceful deletes. We also
have the container kill experiment where you can
send the desired signal to see how your
app or abstracts behave.
Perfect. Thank you.
Alright. I'll let you get back to your
demo now.
Sure. So this is the demo setup that
I have. I just wanted to explain it
for a second before
delving into the demo itself.
So I have a cluster in which
the portal has already been installed,
and it comes with all the Litmus microservices.
We have the Litmus agents,
workflow controller, the kiosk operator,
and I have a metrics exporter
and the actual kiosk experiment CRM artifacts.
There's also monitoring namespace.
So I'm monitoring the Kafka cluster here, and
this is also where we'll observe the request
metrics and
do what we call as chaos interleaved Grafana
dashboards. That is it's essentially a Kafka dashboard
that's also annotated with chaos metrics so you
know happening to your app when kiosk is
going on. And coming to the main workload
itself,
it's a Kafka cluster. I have three brokers.
This image actually shows five. I actually have
three
along with Zookeeper to maintain state.
And as
part of this experiment,
we are going to create some test load.
I'm going to set up a very simple
Kafka producer consumer pair running as two different
containers in a single pod.
And we are going to create a message
stream that has one topic
with just a single partition,
but we are going to replicate that partition
across three brokers.
So you might all know that going to
be a partition leader amongst those three brokers.
It's actually going to handle the data traffic,
the rights.
So we are going to identify
the
partition leader amongst those three brokers, and we're
going to kill them.
Once we kill that, there's going to be
a failover.
There's going to be a partition
a partition leadership
failover. So there's going to be another broker
which is going to take up the leadership
of that partition.
And the broker that we kill might happen
to be just
a partition leader, or it can also be
the active controller or the controller broker,
which is actually keeping this
Kafka cluster together,
orchestrating failovers, speaking to zookeeper, and all that.
So depending upon which of those you kill,
you will will probably see a slight difference
in the in the experiment execution.
And what happens when we kill is, of
course, the failover happens, but the consumer that
we've created
here as part of the test load setup
is configured with a message time out. So
it has a time out on how
much time it can wait for before
it stops receiving IO or data.
And if there's no data received within the
time out, it's going to give up and
the board is actually going to fail.
And if at all, the failover happened quickly
enough
and your your timeout was set correctly for
this environment, and it depends lot on the
environment you are running this in. Depends upon
the storage classes you're using, the network, the
CNI provider, and so many things like that.
So we are going to hypothesize about what's
the right time out. We're going to start
off with something that's small. We're going to
we're going to see how the experiment fails
and what are the information we collect as
part of the failure.
And then we are going to do the
same experiment with the larger time out and
verify
our hypothesis of an unbroken message stream.
Right? And
the experiment should just continue. The message stream
should continue. It should not be broken, all
that.
But but as we do this experiment, this
is essentially the use case that I'm going
to demonstrate.
Many times, when you do your experiments, it's
not just your core
application behavior that you're going to check. You
may have that as one of your main
constraints,
but you also have a few other things
you want to observe as part of your
experiment.
So this is where observability is very important.
You want to know what's happening to different
services when you do your experiment,
and you should be able to visualize that.
And that's why without observability,
chaos is like shooting you know, trying to
shoot a dark cat in a dark room
kind of a thing. So you need observability.
What Litmus also provides is the ability to
consume observability
information from the outside. That is you could
look Litmus has the ability to look for
from it is metrics or the like. For
example, you could basically
say, during this experiment
when I start this experiment and when I
end this experiment, I expect that there are
no offline partitions or under replicated partitions.
During the experiment, when I kill the part,
the broker, it's possible that I may have
under replicated
partitions because one of them is down. But
when I begin and when I end eventually,
I want things to be fine. I should
not have any problems, and I should never
experience data loss,
or the data integrity should be maintained. I
should not have offline partitions.
All those things are
auxiliary checks you want to make,
while the primary constraint is they want to
see my message stream to be unbroken.
So these are things you want to factor
in into your experiment, something that we call
as declarative hypothesis.
Many times, you run your experiment as automated
drums. So you might not be at hand
always to see what's happened. So you want
some things to be automated, some checks to
be automated as well. So we'll do that
in
Litmus.
I will show you how to do that
in the experiment.
And all these steps that I mentioned,
all about the experiment, the prerequisites to set
up the cluster,
what the use cases is about, what's our
hypothesis,
and what are what are the demo steps,
all that has been documented
in
in here. We we recently ran this as
a boot one of the boot camp sessions
during kiosk carnival. So we have all that
information here, so please feel free to take
a look at this after we are done.
Okay.
So without much more discussion, let me just
go ahead
and
wait. Let me go ahead. I have lost
my cluster instance here, but don't really mind
because I have my lens set up
for the same cluster. So you can see
I have
Kafka clusters.
There's three brokers.
I have the Kafka exporter already set up
along with Zookeeper.
And then I also have the Litmus microservices
that I mentioned are running.
And I have a portal here,
in which I have already done several workflows
before this. I'm just going to make use
of the same setup.
So let me schedule
this
experiment around.
I'm going to select,
the self clusters. That is we're going to
do this experiment on the same cluster where
the portal has been installed.
I already have my workflow manifest in my
workspace,
and I'm going to say that I'm going
to create my own workflow.
I'm going to upload
my YAML.
So there is a a workflow manifest
called Kafka WF Multipro.
I've selected that.
So here is where
you see the big manifest. Right? I'll take
a few seconds to describe this. There was
a good question sometime back around, can I
isolate my experiment to particular workflow? So this
is the section where you do it.
You provide the namespace of the workflow of
the workflow,
some
filter
such as the label,
and what is the app kind.
Then there's something interesting. It's called as the
annotation check. I've set it to false here,
but you can actually turn it on. So
what this does is, let's say, there were
multiple
deployments
or multiple stateful sets rather, which share the
same details such as
a alpha.
Maybe one of them was
running with dev image, one was running with
production image,
it's running with, you know, a different fix,
different instrumentation.
You want to target a specific workload. So
I can choose to do a second level
filtering by adding an annotation on the stateful
set called Litmus chaos dot I o slash
chaos set to true. And I can set
this to true. So it's actually going to
find out
all these stateful sets that match this criteria,
but it's also going to check which of
them has the annotation.
And then it's only going to target that
particular app.
And, I'm using the service account, call it
as admin, to run this experiment.
And the chaos engine, which is, what I'm
talking about, also has a way for you
to specify whether you want monitoring turned on
or turned off.
So I have a Kafka
cluster dashboard here on my Grafana. I have
used the standard JMX exporter dashboard,
and we've just instrumented it with Litmus annotations.
So whenever chaos happens, you will see,
those annotations appearing here.
And, if I want,
this monitoring to be enabled on a per
experiment basis, I can choose to send the
monitoring through,
or I can turn it off.
And you can see this is the hypothesis
I mentioned. So right at the beginning and
at the end of the experiment,
we don't want any under replicated partitions.
So I'm querying a Prometheus
server, which is at this endpoint, and this
is the query that I'm going to run.
And I'm, going to do some comparison. I'm
going to check the deviation.
I'm going to look for the desired status
here.
Edge mode for a probe, and we call
these probes on the, declarative hypothesis.
Probes are called probes.
Probes can run-in different modes. Edge indicates that
it is going from the beginning and end
of the experiment.
And we have another probe.
It's the same Prometheus probe. I have a
different metric here,
not just at the beginning and at the
end, but through the experiment duration, I don't
want any offline partitions.
And this is going to be continuous more.
So even as the chaos occurs, we are
going to validate this. There are some run
properties as you can see, as you could
imagine.
These are the polling intervals for this probe
to get executed
and characteristics
for retrying that if there's a failure.
There's also an other probe, which is called
as a command probe, where you can see
I'm running a cube CTL command,
which is something that is telling you that
a pod which has this label, Kafka liveness,
which is essentially the load pod which is
being brought up, should have the consumer
container always ready through the experiment duration
during the chaos period.
And
that's
the indication that the message stream is unbroken
for me. So I have all these probes
set up. Then I have some information about
the Kafka deployment itself, what's the service name,
what's the Zookeeper details,
how do I want to kill, all that
information is provided here in the chaos engine.
So this is the chaos engine.
Once I'm happy with what I have, I'll
go to the next step.
So in Litmus,
we define
or we enable what's called as resiliency
grading.
So this workflow just has one experiment, but
I could choose to have more than one
experiment,
in which case, I can assign some criticality
to those experiments. For example, I'm doing the
part failure with 10 points, but I might
just be doing a network loss with seven
points.
Depends upon how much the experiment means to
you, which is also reflective of how much
your application is already in place already mature
to take those experiments.
So I could choose the weights for the
individual experiments.
And, eventually, this will help me get a
resilience score for this workflow,
which is essentially a ratio of
weight into the experiment success points divided by
the total points.
Right? And that is something you can compare,
release on release, build on build to see
what's happening with your application and how much
you are becoming more resilient.
I just have one experiment, so I'm going
to select all points.
Have an option to schedule experiment
once
or repeat it multiple times according to a
schedule.
I'm going to just do it once.
And,
yeah, that's it. And
if I did not show it to you
clearly,
this experiment is now being run with,
I think, something like seventy five seconds,
if I'm not wrong.
Yeah. So this is something that works on
this cluster.
I can repeat this experiment. I actually wanted
to do this experiment with a lesser time
out, but I just got started.
This time out is actually good enough in
this case
on this Google cluster that I'm running. So
the experiment is expected to pass, and we'll
see how that success is reflected in the
different resources, kiosk resources.
But if you lower that time, it's actually
going to fail. So I think let's take
a look at the success case first today.
Once your workflow is running,
you can see the visualization,
the progress.
So we just pull the chaos experiment here,
and then it started doing the chaos.
If you go to this lens setup, you
can see some parts being brought up. So
the Kafka broker part for you that you
see here is actually the experiment part that
has been brought up to run the chaos
business logic.
Right? And it actually started a liveness part
here, which is the test flow.
And
I can basically show you what
that is going to throw out. There are
three containers. I'm just going to show the
Kafka consumer.
It's basically a very, very simple message stream.
You can see that it is just going
to print a string and with and time
stamp.
It identified the leader broker, the partition leader
to be Kafka one, so you can actually
see that this is going down.
And it has a readiness probe, so it's
actually going to take some time before it
actually comes up.
Right? In that period, we want we don't
we don't want this container
to give up. We don't want the consumer
to give up and throw an exception saying
the timeout has been exceeded. It has to
pause and then continue.
That's our hypothesis.
And along the way, verify a host of
other things, offline partitions, and particular partitions, and
all that. You can see seventy five seconds
was good enough. So it's a pretty slow
setup. That's why I had to give a
bigger timeout. The message stream is actually continuing.
As you can see, it's not broken.
So that's good news because you got your
time out right in your first chart. The
hypothesis was validated, but often, it doesn't happen
like this. You have to play around a
little bit in order to actually come to
the right conclusion.
So I'm talking in the perspective of you
running chaos experiments to identify what is a
good deployment attribute. But just if you just
flip this logic,
you could you could run this on production,
and you could just to find out if
the things are all working good, what worked
earlier, and does it continue to work today,
all of that stuff. So
you can see the Kafka
pods here. The
the pod is going to come up. It
has been restored its original state.
And while all this is happening,
if you take a look at the the
Kafka
Grafana dashboard, you can see this red area
here. It is actually indicating the period of
chaos.
So while chaos is happening, you just have
two brokers. You don't have three. So you
have some other replicated partitions,
which will and did eventually recover when you
have all the brokers.
And you could see the
the broker count. It assumed the the broker
that was killed probably happened to be the
active controllers. We did not get a broker
count value here, but it's resumed after that.
You can also get these annotations on all
your panels if you do it as a
refund annotation.
So you you can identify what happened during
your your chaos,
what
metric did, what increased, all that information, you
can find it.
Right? And we have done this a few
times over the
last few hours, so you can actually see
that
done across multiple times. So if you have
not been on your system or you've you've
been away and want to find out what
happened
when you went away and when chaos was
executed,
what were the metrics? You can you can
use this. This is what we call as
interleaved dashboards, chaos interleaved app dashboards.
And the
metrics are something that you can find. There
are a host of other metric. I just
use the request chaos experiments to obtain this
annotations, but there are also other experiments that
you could make use of to construct dashboards
of your choice. And
with that, let's take a quick look at
what happened to the experiment part. So the
experiment part is here. It's actually completed.
And
I used
a job cleanup policy of retain. So I
I can choose the
choose for Litmus parts to be removed at
the end of chaos, or I can choose
for them to remain in completed state for
me to go and check what has happened.
So these are the pods. And if you
just scroll up, you will actually see that
it look for some default checks whether the
application is alive before starting the chaos.
And after doing the chaos or doing chaos,
it checked several of these metrics that we
wanted it to with what we're defined in
the probes. The lep replicated partitions failed in
the first check, but we provided some retries
and timeouts.
Eventually,
it succeeded.
If you want it a more stringent kind
of a check, you can reduce the timeouts
and retries.
And there were no offline partitions. It was
always available.
And finally,
the message stream continuity check probe
did did succeed eventually.
So there was
the consumer part, which it always found to
be running. So this is something that
determines
the the hypothesis.
So you can run your experiment,
see what has happened during the course of
your experiment using the the request portal. So
request portal is a a cool way to
see what's happening. Experiments still shows us running
because it is doing a few post chaos
checks for post processing operations
and filling in details into your logs, which
you will eventually be able to notice.
So once this ends, you can actually go
and view your logs. So you have a
logs button here, which you can always use
to see the same information similarly to the
way that you saw the information on Lends.
So this was about
how we run the Kafka experiment for a
success case.
And I mentioned that
there is something called the results.
Let me show that very quickly.
This actually gets created. Okay. I'm on a
different setup.
Let me do this on my actual console.
Okay. You can do it on Lens as
well. So there's something called custom resources.
It was chaos.ivo
and chaos the result. Yeah. So here it
is.
So you can see there's
the customer source. It has information about what
happened to your individual probes
and what happened eventually to your experiment. It
has the status of
the experiment currently,
and
you will be able to use this information
to generate some useful
reports
to see what has happened with your different
chaos arms. It has some metadata as well,
what experiment is running, and what chaos engine
it belong to.
All that information is available here.
So this was about the chaos result,
and this is how we went ahead and
ran an experiment.
So I just can take some questions here
before I move on to the next part
of the demo. I can do the failure
on for this, but it's going to be
the same. A couple of probes are going
to fail, and the chaos result is going
to show up as fail instead of fast.
So that's about how you can run a
chaos experiment
using the portal. This is how you can
define your hypothesis using probes and how you
can visualize things using the portal.
And
you also saw the kiosk result. Yeah. That's
all I had to show as part of
this demonstration.
And I can actually go ahead and show
the
next
chaos experiment,
is going to do chaos not on Kubernetes
pod,
but instead on
an easy to instance,
right, on Amazon Cloud. So Omar mentioned during
his talk that
you could provide details of your cloud,
the credentials, and it's going to use the
API provided by the cloud provider and go
ahead and inject some chaos. Getting started on
this stream,
not Kubernetes chaos, but we do have a
few useful experiments that you can already start.
But before I actually go ahead and show
that, I just wanted to,
you know, take some questions if
there are any around what we just discussed.
Yeah. So we have
the launch, like I mentioned.
Yeah. I guess there's a a few things
kind of floating around my head. Like, what's
in involved in protecting support for additional probes
beyond, like, the, you know, the Prometheus probe,
the command probe. Like, you know, if I
wanted to support,
maybe taking a look at some logs in
low key or creating influx DB or even
reaching out to external systems to understand maybe,
fee actual user
feedback or request. Like, are the probes complicated,
or is there something I can throw together
pretty quickly?
Yeah. So the probe documentation is available here.
You can take a look at the different
kind of probes.
We use the Prometheus probe and the command
probe in our current experiment.
There are also a few others. There's a
HTTP probe, which can which you can use
to get the availability of some downstream applications.
You could provide the response code,
and you could do get post
different kind of HTTP commands.
And verify if things are good here, there's
something called as a KTSPRO,
which is essentially trying to
get information about Kubernetes resources.
So there are a lot of custom and
native resources on your cluster whose status you
might want to observe,
especially in the age of,
you know, operators.
There are a lot of applications that are
being managed by operators,
and you will find a lot of information
about the health of those applications in CRs
pertaining to them. So if you want to
get information
about those, you can also use
KTIS probes. But it is a great point,
David.
We can always extend these probes. The way
they are being written is
we're trying to make it a modular thing
so you can actually fit in more probes.
You can have more probe sources or probe
types.
You can have probes that are specific
to some service measures. Say, for example, you
can have something related to Thanos or Loki.
Yeah. You you you can create
probes like that, and
there there there has been a lot of
interest in creating new type of probes as
well as trying to extend this probe framework
to
do things like chain the probes and conditional
probes,
running some probes on it depending upon the
result of others,
and trying to use the output of one
probe as input in another, which is what
we're calling as chaining.
All that is something we are working towards
to improve this hypothesis validation framework.
Definitely,
something to consider,
and we'll be really happy to take more
user feedback about this.
An issue on GitHub would be great.
Yeah. I think that part of it really
interesting. You know? I you know, I because
it's a cloud native project and people are
running Kubernetes, you know, there are a lot
of people that are using Prometheus. Right? That
makes a lot of sense. And why that
exists as a, you know, one of the
first set of groups.
Being with the rise of OpenTelemetry
and that agnostic layer to where we store
metrics, you know, a lot more people are
now starting to look at like, data
Datadog or Honeycomb and been able to query
those as part of that probe, think, would
be really important.
Okay. Absolutely. What
if I wanna get rather destructive
using Litmus skills? Like, actually attacking the Kubernetes
API server to see what happens to my
cluster.
Is that ill advised, or is that something
that is potentially possible? And I'm curious about
the way that things are reconciled when if
I do break the API server.
Yeah. We've had people try few things like
that.
So what happens
if it's something that's a transient error, like
you said,
destroying the I mean, filling the API server
part for a few seconds or minutes before
it actually comes back. I think it's something
that's doable. You might see things sort of
getting stalled for some time. You might not
see
outputs and logs and things like that, but
they'll eventually
get filled back once the
Litmus the Kubernetes control when component is back
up. So we've had people doing that kind
of case. But if we want to do
something
larger scale, something more destructive for a longer
period of time,
something that is being discussed in Litmus circles
by
we will be able to or we will
enable doing chaos on Kubernetes control plane itself
by staying outside the cluster. The Litmus experiment
business logic allows you to do that.
But today, it runs as a pod. There
are also plans of running it as via
CLI where you sort of effectively outside the
cluster. You don't really run as pod,
but you're still able to go kill things.
You're using k this API,
you also have other checks to see if
your API is not responsive, how how long
you can wait for the experiment to continue
to run, then check the status and things
like that.
So so you could do it today, but
only for transient errors. But if you want
to do it for longer periods of time
in a much more destructive way, clean Kubernetes
itself,
I think that's something that we will enable
over time. Having said that, there are a
lot of add ons that people run-in Kubernetes,
something that you you also you could also
see on the portal. There's there is a
category of experiments called SQ components
or something that the Intuit folks have been
driving in
for some for some time, which is essentially
some add ons that they have in their
Kubernetes
clusters.
So there's some Prometheus
and some Ingress controllers and Qproxy and few
things different controller, few things like that. So
you could actually
you wouldn't call them as most important, of
course, queue proxies,
but
there are a lot of supportive tools when
you run your Kubernetes
workloads,
when you're bringing up your staging or your
production.
It's not only going to contain Kubernetes and
your business applications, but as a host of
other things from the CNCF ecosystem that
form your
overall framework. It could be observability. It could
be compliance things. It could be databases. It
could be so many things. So you could
use Litmus not just for your core application,
but you will use it for other infra
components as well. And if that infra component
happens to be the Kubernetes control plane itself,
some of it is possible today, and some
of it is going to be enabled in
the future.
Yeah. Okay. I think that's a really interesting
thing, like, when there is a component that
runs as state of of Kubernetes. Because I
can imagine bringing in, you know, maybe pro
to even chaos experiments themselves to integrate or
work with eBPF and really start to do
some crazy stuff there would be a lot
of I I don't wanna say fun, but
it does kinda sound like fun. So
Yeah. Alright. I think that's the only questions
I have right now. If you wanna do
this, the failure demo, and then we can
we can do a quick demo. I think
there's
just one small thing about doing chaos on
easy two instances.
I can probably just share that.
It's probably not going to take too much
time.
It's very sim simple, very similar to what
we did with the Kafka experiment. I'm just
going to schedule a workflow,
and
I create my own workflow.
And I can upload my YAML that has
the easy to terminate stuff
here.
And
you can see that this chaos engine is
basically trying to kill an instance which has
this ID. It can also kill instances randomly
if you choose to. Has some details here.
And this particular experiment also uses a cloud
secret,
which I already have on my cluster.
So there are some secrets that I created
here
for
holding information about my
and this is on next cluster, I think.
Alright. I think it's the same one. Yeah.
So there is a secret which holds information
about my AWS
access.
So I'm just going to go ahead and
run this,
and you know about the residency scores.
Yeah. And it's going to run a new
experiment.
And the idea for that is one of
these plus instance IDs, this one, to be
precise, is actually going to be stopped for
some time.
And this node happens to be a worker
node of the Kubernetes plus the Kubernetes, Kubernetes
plus the AWS.
So in case you want to do something
more disruptive
at a workload level, you have
you do have node related experiments in Litmus,
which are only using KTAS API, like, we
have node drain.
You basically create eviction
things and push out all the parts to
effectively simulate
node shutdown,
things like that. But if you want to
go and do something hard resets
like that at the provider level, you could
still do that.
And
these are experiments that will help you to
do that.
So this experiment is going to be in
progress.
You could you can see that there are
some
easy to terminate experiment parts that have come
up here, which are actually going to do
this experiment.
And in this experiment, the hypothesis is very
simple. It is going to kill a node.
I want to see a part, an engine
x part. This is scheduled successfully, and it
is coming back to running state.
More like a vanilla
vanilla case of a chaos experiment.
So
let me go ahead and
show you my easy to instances.
I think I need to do this.
Yeah. You can see that it has been
stopped,
and it's going to come back to running
state. The hypothesis also includes
to includes to check on whether all the
all the nodes in this cluster are back
to running states. We want to leave the
cluster
in a similar state as we started it.
So it's going to check whether things are
all online
after it gets back.
So
that's essentially what this experiment does. And, yeah,
you can see that it was brought back.
So that's very quickly how
you could run experiments on AWS instances. You
can also do EBS detach, do something similar
on Google Cloud as well.
So yeah. So that's about how you can
run different guest experience using the portal.
A lot of these workflows
and
the information on how you can set up
clusters and how you can run these experiments
are available here. You can share that on
the chat or on the YouTube, like, video
comments.
So please feel free to take a look
at that.
That's pretty much what I had done, David,
in terms of installation
and then how you can run experiments.
Awesome. We covered an awful lot there. Really
interesting stuff. I hope other people kind of
enjoyed what they see and they go and
give Litmus a a play in their own.
Alright. We've gone a little bit over, but
I'll just give you both the opportunity. Is
there anything you would to finish on just
now? Anything you'd like to say before we
say goodbye to our audience and leave some
of that?
Yeah. I think we can stick around for
a few minutes and take any questions.
Alright.
If everyone has any questions, you got thirty
seconds. Drop them in the chat or forever
hold your peace. The show notes will include
all of the links that were covered by
both Ooma and Kartik. They will be available
in the YouTube description.
And,
yeah, I hope people enjoy Plymouth Tuckness.
Alright. I don't think we're gonna get any
more questions. Alright. I just wanna say thank
you both for joining me today. Really interesting
project. Lots of really exciting stuff there for
people to do and play with. The demos
were were great. It was good to see,
you know, that, you know, some of those
experiments can resolve nicely, which I hope we
all hope. But of course, when they go
bad, at least we have the visibility of
the margin and observability. All those other tools
that we really people to do. Do not
go unleashing chaos into your clusters when you're
not ready. Right? Very dangerous.
Alright. Thank you both again. I hope you
have a great day,
and I'll speak to Austin. You too. Cheers.
Bye. Thank you. Cheers.